[Music]
this is the aluminum ball challenge we
are doing the aluminum foil ball
challenge it swept the internet it was
pretty much people making smooth shiny
balls out of aluminum foil it originated
in japan but the story doesn't end there
it gets more meta because this challenge
actually came from another tradition in
japan and in true japanese fashion that
tradition is pretty spectacular
dolodango is a japanese art form in
which earth and water are molded to
create a delicate shiny sphere
that's a nice way of saying that these
are very fancy mudballs
and when it comes to making dolodango in
japan kyoko miki is one of the best
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
the process condensed goes like this
get a clay-based mud mix it with hay
this helps keep it from falling apart
roll it into a sphere and leave it to
dry in the sun
[Music]
[Music]
and the story doesn't end here because
where there is something beautiful there
is a competition to prove who is the
best and kyoko is a judge
this is the annual dolodango tournament
in tokonami japan
[Music]
this year contestants from all over
japan have come to showcase their work
looks like they've got a winner so what
does a winning dollar dangle look like
very shiny
[Music]
colored plain large small the dolla
dango is not a one-look pony it
exemplifies so much of japanese culture
patience perfection and the pursuit of
beauty in everyday things
and they're also pretty cool to look at
you